No mutta tässä pitää vaan muistaa
ettei tee niitä virheitä.
Ne.
miten te, kun te ajattelette ja puhutte
englanniksi vaikka töissä,
niin ajatteletteko te englanniksi silloin
vai ajatteletteko te suomeksi sitten?
Kaikki maailman ihmiset ajattelee
Suomeksi.
Sehän nyt on ihan tiedetty fakta.
Hmm.
yks kohta oli siellä että
porttilaatikolle ei voi antaa salasanaovea
käsin.
Hei!
Mikä mallit on käänsyä?
Ja sit mä olin et mit...
Opus. Joo. Porttilaatikkoa ei voi a...
Opus.
No ihan hyvä. Kyllä mä ymmärrän ton
niin. Porttilaatikolle
ei voi antaa salasana ovea käsin.
Mä ymmärrän mikä ongelma.
Joo joo kyllä sokeesti voi luottaa.
Laitas se bullshit label tähänkin.
Se on tekoäly. Niin,
Niin. Muistitko, sanoit make no mistakes?
En
no mistakes
sanonut. Eli tässä voi olla nyt
virheitä,
vaikkei pitäisi olla.
No mutta tässä pitää vaan muistaa
ettei tee niitä virheitä.
Ne.
Sama totta.
Sen kummempaa
Ajattelin, että jos lähtisi liikkeelle
siitä,
että nyt on tullut Open AI:lta AGIa
mimmosta maailma
on nyt tälleen niinku post-agi,
mimmost teidän arki on, nyt kun ei
tarvitse itse enää tehdä mitään.
Aloittaaks Valtteri?
Kyllähän se on muuttunut.
Ihan erilainen. Maanantaina kun heräs
niin ei vielä tiennyt,
miten tämä viikko muuttaa elämää.
Onhan se ihan selvä.
Sääköl.
Kaikki tapahtuu Astra kanssa nyt vaan.
Ei tarve itse tehdä
Joo.
enää mitään.
Joo. Joo, kyllä se...
Onko te testannut sitä Astraa?
No ei, mä en oo... Siis, mun pitäis
päästä irti tästä.
Tää on vähän niin kuin Windows,
Microsoft 90-luvulla, OpenA on mulle
sellanen punainen vaate
nyt ollu jostain syystä tosi pitkään.
Mä en vaan jotenkin hyväksy sitä
niitten eetosta,
miten he on vetänyt täs viimeisten
vuosien aikana.
Ehkä se on vaan niin kuin itselle ha...
haitallista ajatella tälleen.
Sen takia just pääosin Anthropicin ja
Googlen kanssa ajelen niitä.
Eli OpenAI
on tekoälyfirmojen Windows
tai miten se muotoilisi, niin Microsoft.
Mikrosoft. Niin, mutta kun Mikrosoftkin
on parantanut juoksuaan tässä,
niin ei mulla ole enää niin suuria
antipatioita,
Ei.
tosiaan kun silloin niin kuin Linux ja OS
kaks miehenä 90-luvulla.
Mikä on sitten näiden isojen pelureiden
Linux,
jos verrataan AI-firmoihin?
Niin.
No eikö se ole joku näistä
kiinalaisista sit varmaan?
avoimet painot.
Niin, ZAI on kovas nosteessa sen GLM:n
kanssa.
Mistral voisi olla.
Mistra on kyllä, kyllä, kyllä.
Meinasin just sanoo et mikä Mistral on.
Mistral taitaa tehdä aika paljon
enterprise-tyyppistä kauppaa.
Nimenomaan, kyllä.
Niillä on ehkä vähemmän tätä
hype-juna meininkiä.
Joo ja heidän strategia kyl selkeästi
erottuu muista,
että en tiedä onko se sitten pakon
edessä vai muuten tullut just
et ei tapella siellä niinku frontier
mallien kanssa vaan mennään bisnes
edellä
ja heillähän on paljon just tuota niinku
enterprise asiakkaita
ja konennäköä ja näitä juttuja mitkä
on varsinkin kaikki
ne Mistralin OCR mallit on ainakin
itsellä kun mä oon niitä testannut niin
toiminut aika hyvin.
ja nopeita ja kustannustehokkaita.
Hmm. Kyllä.
Semmosia
työjuhtamalleja.
Kyllä. Se on aina, jos miettii tätä
suvereniteettikysymystä,
se, että meillä on eurooppalaisia
kilpailijoita,
jotka pystyy pistää kampoihin noille
isommille jenkkiläisille,
niin se on aika iso asia. tiedä siitä
vaan,
miten jatkossa.
Noin kiinalaiset, kiinalaiset tavoimet
mallit tietysti,
niin kun tasoittaa sitä pelikenttää
aika tehokkaasti,
koska niitä sitten pystyy pyörittää
joko
vuokratulla raudalla Euroopassa tai omalla
raudalla vaikka toimiston nurkassa,
jossa on tarpeeksi tehokas kone.
Se on silleen mun mielestä ihan hyvä
asia,
vaikka tästäkin nyt sitten tietysti
saatiin,
oliko tänään vai eilen, kun oli juttu
siitä,
että isoimmat pelurit haluaisivat
hidastaa tätä tekoälyn kehitysvauhtia.
En tiedä sitten, mitä siitäkin pitäisi
miettiä.
Sehän yksi Anthropicin tyyppi,
joka irtisanoutui, hänen tämmöinen
tweet meni viraaliksi,
jossa hän oli sitä mieltä, että
ihmiskunta tuhoaa itsensä.
Tekoälyn kanssa.
Jotenkin vaan en tiedä, onko sitä niin
kyynistynyt,
että mä vaan mietin, että siellä joku
ajattelee,
että kohta mennään julkiseksi näiden,
listaudutaan näiden yritysten kanssa,
niin pumpataan niinku kaikin
mahdollisimman tavoin sitä arvoa
Hmm.
niinku ylöspäin
tämmöistä doomer, doomsday niinku
skenaarioiden kanssa.
Tai sitten toinen vaihtoehto, alkaa
tavallaan se näkymään,
ettei niitä saada enää parannettua
niitä malleja.
Nii.
Ja sitten sanotaan, että pitää hidastaa
tahtia.
Keksitään tämmöinen juttu.
Niin.
Kyllä.
Tässä on tosi vaikea enää erottaa,
mikä on sitä markkinointihypeä ja mikä
on aitoa.
Kyllä
Hmm.
kaikki tällaiset vahvat julkilausumat,
just tämä GPT Astra oli aika vahva,
semmoinen, mun mielestä ei taidettu ihan
suoraan sanoa,
että se olisi AGi, mutta ollaan astumassa
AGin aikakaudelle,
josko se ollut jotenkin näin.
Mmm... Mii...
Niin aika
semmoista hypeä.
hypehommaa ja yrittää erotella
markkinointipuheesta totuuksia
Niin ja kuitenkin jos miettii,
että itsekin päivittäin noiden kanssa
tekee töitä noiden ihan vaikka Fablen
kanssa ja noin niin kyllä ne ihan hyvii
on,
kyllä silti vaan kyllä niitäkin aina
tarvitsee olla sitten korjailemassa
ja varsinkin sitten mulla on niin kuin mun
päätyöjuhtana on Opus
5 niin jotenkin tuntuu välillä,
että pitäisikö vaan mennä takaisin
siihen 4.8. versioon
Se on.
Ootte käytettäkste opusta itse?
Joo, ja
Hmm.
mulla on käs vähän sama, että Fable on
usein ollu semmonen vähän niinku
planinkirjoitusmalli
Jep.
ja sit taas niinku opukselle on sit
tykitellyt sitä niinku varsinaista hommaa
eteenpäin.
Joo. Mut sit just ku opuksen kanssa niin
et tuntuu,
et se on menny se niinku ensinnäkin
siitä on tullu tosi laveasanainen
se silloin se on ihan oma kieli mitä se
käyttää,
siellä on load bearing ja siellä tulee
paljon tämmösiä termejä niinku koko
ajan vastaan ja this will seriously bite
you ja tota sit se
on niinku tosi proaktiivinen mikä on kans
niinku tuntuu et se jossain
Sitäkin oli saatu himmattua jossain
kohtaa,
että se ei ole niin proaktiivinen.
Eilenkin opus 5.
pysäytti sekä kaverina että omat
palvelut.
Selvitteli, että kysyin, että mitä teet
siellä toisen worktreessa.
Minä ajattelin, että mitä sitten...
Sitten aina, että sinä täysin oikein ja
minä ei ole pitänyt sen.
Sitten aina kauheat selittelyt perään.
Kyllä se jotenkin tuntuu, että ehkä
tässä käytetään niin AGI-ssäkin,
että mikä se Open AI määritelmä,
kun tästä niin kuin paljon puhutaan,
että AGI on siellä niin kun me ei
varmaan edes,
kolme ymmärretä sitä sanaa samalla
tavalla niin miten he sitten
Mmm.
niin kun määrittelee sen. Tääkin just
tämä AGI-benchi,
missä he olivat saaneet sen 99.9 niin he
olivat vähän siinä sitten niin
kun kiertäneet sääntöjä, kun he
olivat tehneet siihen oman harnessin.
ja perusteli sitä sillä, että näinhän
muutkin harnessit toimivat.
siis, kun jokainen ymmärtää,
ihmiset, suunnittelee sen benchmarkin ja
harnessin,
ne suunnitellaan yhdessä toimimaan.
Ja tavallaan se määrittelee sen
vaikeustason sille,
eikä sille, että voit ottaa vain toisen
ja vaihtaa toisen.
Ja silti olettaa tavallaan,
että voi sanoa, väittää samoja
asioita.
Niin sekin oli vähän ja muistatteks te
tämmöisenä,
että itse asiassa joku oli tehnyt sen
agibenciin,
myöskin saanut jotkut ihan superhyvät
pisteet siinä,
he oli myös muuttaneet sitä harnessia
vähän samalla tavalla.
Niin siis noihin pitäisi olla
vertailukelpoisia.
Hmm.
Ja muutakin toi, että jos verrataan
avoimia malleja jossain benchmarkissa Open
Hmm.
AI:n tai Anthropicin malleihin,
mitä käytetään sitä rajapinnan
kautta,
niin eihän sitä tiedä mitä siellä
rajapinnan takana tapahtuu.
Että siellähän voidaan tehdä vaikka
mitä kikkailuita.
Siellä voi olla kymmenen mallia ajaa
sitä tai kymmenen instanssia
ja sitä samaa pyyntöä ja valitaan paras
vaihtoehto.
Hmm.
tai jotain
vastaavaa teistä tiedä. Jos
Niin, kyllä.
ajatte ottaa Qwenin tai Kimin
vertailukohdaksi niin se on täysin avoin,
mitä siinä tapahtuu.
Niin. Just näin. Ja tota...
Oikein muista edes, missä vaiheessa
tämä meni tähän benchmarkkiin.
Ruvettiin enemmän, että tässä on
nämä benchmarkit ja hyvin pitkälti
kun uusi malli julkaistaan, sitten tuntuu,
alkaa olla vähän benchmaxxingia Mallit
Hmm.
pärjäävät tosi hyvin benchmarkeissa ja
käytännössä ne
ei kuitenkaan elä siihen.
Terminal Benchissä saatiin vaikka
parikymmentä pinnaa lisää niin
käytännön
elämässä kun itse sitä käyttää niin
se nyt niin paljon parempi
Hmm.
Ainoa
mitä se osaa niin käyttää mykyään
Perliä Se oli jotenkin ihan älytön
Jep.
kanssa. Huomasin yhtäkkiä että se
käyttää Perliä vaan kaikkien scriptien
tekoon. Tämä on kiva, mä oon itsekin
ysärillä tehnyt tätä.
Nii!
Nostalgia.
Mutta tuntuu, että tulee vastaan,
että missä se palkinto, millainen
palkintomekanismi sinulla on siinä,
onko se benchmarking scoret, niin sitten
se ohjaa sitä,
mihin niitä malleja koulutetaan ja sitten
tuntuu,
että ainoa tapa vaan saada se fiilis,
kun tulee joku uusi malli, niin on vaan ne
omat käytännön use-caset
ja sitten katsoa, miltä se tuntuu,
just semmonen vibe-checki tavallaan.
Kyllä.
ja huomannut just että...
Jos vertaa vanhempaa opusta ja nykyistä,
niin se onko siellä tapahtunut sellainen
model implosion,
termi, että se on koulutettu Claude Coden
koulutusmateriaalilla liikaa.
Siellä on ollut paljon monimutkaisia
planeja,
joita ihmiset ovat hyväksyneet Nämä nyt
hyviä inputteja state
Kyllä. Kyllä.
State of the art.
of
the art ja kaikki alkaa...
Se rupeaa puhumaan semmoisella
kompleksilla vähän teknisellä
plänikielellä koko
ajan. Mun mielestä
Kiva.
se heijastuu tuolla ihan käytännön
Clauden deskarikäytössäkin.
Kun et tee koodi-juttuja, niin se
kielitaito on jotenkin huonontunut tosi
paljon.
Vaatinkin suomen kieli on mennyt ihan
Joo.
alamäkeen.
Kyllä. Joo,
Hmm.
ja siis suomenkieli on tosiaan niin
kuin...
Siis se on huonontunut. Must tuntuu,
että se on jotenkin kautta...
Open AI:lla oli aika hyvä Suomi ja se on
huomattavasti parempi
se Suomi vielä nykyäänkin, mitä
Claudel.
Ollaan nyt jonkun verran käännetty ekat
versiot, niin tehty softasta aina
kieliversiointi,
niin Suomen kieli ollaan käännetty
siitä englanninkielestä.
Mutta jos se välillä tuntuu,
että se englanninkielikin on tosi
vaikeaa.
No sit niinku paras just viime
keskiviikkona nii meidän yks merkkijono
mikä
me käännettiin ni se oli se yks kohta
oli siellä että porttilaatikolle
ei voi antaa salasanaovea käsin.
Hei!
Mikä mallit on käänsyä?
Ja sit mä olin et mit...
Opus. Joo. Porttilaatikkoa ei voi a...
Opus.
No ihan hyvä. Kyllä mä ymmärrän ton
niin. Porttilaatikolle
ei voi antaa salasana ovea käsin.
Mä ymmärrän mikä ongelma.
Mielestäni
kieli huono siinä kohtaa, kun tuli
reasoning tai thinking-mallit,
miksi niitä kutsuukaa. Sen jälkeen ne
tuntui,
että ne alkivat suomen kielessä olemaan
paljon huonompia.
En tiedä, johtuuks ne siitä,
että jos katsoo sen verran, mitä niitä
näkee reasoning-traces,
niin ne ovat yleensä englanniksi.
Vaikuttaako se asia, että ne ajattelee
eri kielellä ja
ne varmaan lennosta kääntää sen
lopullisen vastauksen.
Ja se voi olla se, että
koulutusmateriaalit ovat keikahtaneet niin
vahvasti
Englantiin, että Suomi jää koko ajan.
Synte...
Nimenomaan koulutus perustuu synteettiseen
materiaaliin enemmän
ja enemmän ja sitä tuotetaan varmaan
englanniksi.
Mutta tuo on itseasiassa ihan
mielenkiintoinen ajatus siinä mielessä,
että me rupesin miettimään sitä,
että miten te, kun te ajattelette ja
puhutte englanniksi vaikka töissä,
niin ajatteletteko te englanniksi silloin
vai ajatteletteko te suomeksi sitten?
Kaikki maailman ihmiset ajattelee
Suomeksi.
Sehän nyt on ihan tiedetty fakta.
Hmm.
Koska minäkin ajattelen Suomeksi.
Hyvä kysymys. Kyllä sanon,
että kyllä ne ajatukset on Suomeksi ja
sen takia varmaan kielen tuotto
Englanniksi
onkin vähän just hitaampaa. Siellä on
se reasoning tapahtuu Suomeksi
ja sitten pitää kääntää se
tavallaan.
Nii.
En tiedä mitä kaksikielisillä mahtaa
olla.
Kyllä se on varmaan kyse.
Kyllä luulen, kaksikieliselläkin hyvä
tälleen arvailla kun on yksikielinen.
Tuna.
Hmm.
Veikkaat, kyllä niilläkin on se
pääajattelukieli.
Mutta kyllä englannissa on mennyt ehkä
siihen,
että siinä ajattelee aika paljon
englanniksi.
Joo, kyllä mä ite kans nyt kun mietin,
niin jos mä puhun englanniksi,
niin kyllä mä niin kuin myöskin pyrin
ajattelemaan englanniksi
ja jotta just siinä, koska toi oli mun
mielestä aika hyvä huomio,
jos se niinku thinking,
ajattelu, ajatteluosio siitä kontekstista
menee aina englanniksi,
niin sithän niinkun, jos sä mietit sitä
mekanismia,
miten toi, tota, miten nää LLM:t.
toimii, niin silloinhan se tavallaan
kiinnittää niihin edellisiin tokeneihin
huomioon, jotka on eri kielellä,
niin silloinhan se väistämättä alkaa
mennä vähän niin kuin hassuksi.
Sitten tulee suora
Ja sieltä tulee ne lauserakenteet
Hmm.
suomennos, kuten sanoit, portti,
homma sulla olikaan
Salasanaportti, kyllä. Eiku hetkinen
siis porttilaatikkoa. Porttilaatikolle ei
voi antaa salasanaovea käsin.
Täällä kyllä.
ja kyllä
mun on pakko korjata siis kyllä mäkin
ajattelen englanniksi
Joo.
Kyllä.
Tiedosti.
Ettei vaan jää jälkeen.
Just näin.
Sitten on asioita, voi jotain numeroita ja
muuta ajatella suomeksi.
Jotain tiettyjä teemoja voi olla helpompi
käydä päässään,
ollaan toisella kielellä
Kyllä.
Toinen
vähän tämmönen side quest,
side note ajatus, mutta muistaakseni
olisin joskus lukenut,
pitää varmaan tehdä joku fact check ja
tehdä semmosia factobokseja tähän
sit jakson päälle vielä, että mikä
oli oikea vastaus,
This is bullshit
mut this is bullshit, on ne
varoitus, että älä kuuntele,
skippaa seuraavat
Hei
viisi minuuttia. Mutta mä muistelisin
joskus,
että niinkuin Kiina olisi ollut
huomattavasti paljon esimerkiksi niinku
tokenitehokkaampi, koska sehän on niin
kuin symbolinen kieli
jo niin kuin sellaisenaan. Sen
Huh?
kouluttaminen ja sitten ne reasoning
traceit ja kaikkea
on paljon tehokkaampia tavallaan
tämmöisellä transformerilla,
koska se yhdessä merkissä on niin paljon
enemmän tavallaan merkitystä.
Niin
Hmm.
onhan suomenkieli keskimäärin kalliimpi
kuin englanninkielen tuottaminen
kielimallille. Se käyttää enemmän
tokeneita.
Siellä on valmiita tokeneita enemmän
tietysti englanninkieleen,
koska se on siihen suunniteltu.
Niitä ei kai... Eiks mahtavaa niitä,
et ne isommil valtakielillä, niihin se
tavallaan niinku taipuu.
Tai siellä on tokenizerissa varmaan
enemmän niinkun valmiita palasia.
Onks
Ne.
se pelkästään englanti vai onks se
niinku noi kaikki päikielet?
Tää onkin hyvä kysymys.
Sehän perustuu koulutustataan.
Kun rakennat sen tokenizerin ja syötät
niitä sanoja,
niin sithän se automaattisesti yrittää
löytää tehokkaimmat tavat esittää
kielenpaloja.
Hmm.
Minusta tuntuu, että suurin osa,
kun on englanniksi, niin tokenisaatio
on optimaalisimmillaan just englannille.
No.
mutta
kuinka paljon se tavallaan latinan kautta
sitten vertautuu muihin
samantyyppisiin kieliin, sitä en osaa
sanoa.
No tota hauska testi. Siellä Open
AI:llakin on se Tokenizeri
Hmm.
työkalu, niin siinä on ihan hauska.
Mulla on se vakkariesimerkki, on varmaan
Valtterilta joskus oppinut,
ice cream ja jäätelö, niin kirjoittaa
molemmat sinne ja sitten voi näyttää,
että mitä hyvin Suomi taipuu verrattuna
Englantiin.
Ice cream taisi olla kolme tokenia,
jäätelöpuikko oli joku, en mä tiedä,
kaheksan jotain.
Niin, kyllä.
tai ei tää nyt ole fact-checkiä,
kun Claude tekee tätä,
Joo joo kyllä sokeesti voi luottaa.
Laitas se bullshit label tähänkin.
Se on tekoäly. Niin,
Niin. Muistitko, sanoit make no mistakes?
En
no mistakes
sanonut. Eli tässä voi olla nyt
virheitä,
vaikkei pitäisi olla.
GPT3 oli 50 000 tokenia
Joo.
GPT4:ssa 200 000 tokenia tai GPT-4o:sta
tai ylöspäin.
Toki en tiiä onko se muuttunut,
johonkin Astra on tullut, voi olla
sellainen uusi tokenaiseri,
mutta on se kasvanut.
Joo, on kasvanut ihan huimasti,
että kun sinne on täytynyt saada tuo
munakoisoemoji ja kaikki muut mukaan,
Totta.
niin yhdellä tokenilla esitettäväksi.
Tää sanoo
et Finnish still expensive in absolute
terms
3.4 characters per token,
vs 5.2 for english
Kyllä siinä on sitten ihan huomattava
ero.
Et on se ei ihan tuplat, melkeen.
Sitten se vaikuttaa myös, ei
pelkästään se,
luulen, että vaikuttaa varmaan siihen
laatuun myös,
että miten tiettyihin sanan osin on ne
painot liitetty suomen
kielessä, mutta vaikuttaa myös
prosessointinopeuteen,
että kun tekee Suomeksi jotain,
matskuu vaikka tietotyössä, niin onhan
se hitaampaa tuottaa sitä tekstiä,
jolla on opuksellakin, koska siitä tulee
niin paljon sitä tokenia ulos.
Kyllä. Käytättekö te noita Cerebraksen
apejä johonkin?
onko... Koska siis se...
Ei ollut kuin testikäytössä.
Joo, mulla
on sama... Pitäisi taas koittaa,
koska siis tota... Mulla on tosi hyviä
kokemuksia siitä Qwen 3.8:sta Että
mä fyynäsin tuohon meidän omaan
AI-purnukkaan
sen käyttöön ja säädin vähän noit
LLama CPP:n
parametreja ja se generoi aika tymäkkää
vauhtia sieltä tavaraa ulos,
kun nyt katoin, että Cerebras tarjoaisi
sitä myös ja se
on tuhansia tokeneita sekunnissa.
Se voisi olla aika mielenkiintoista.
Olette kuullut tämmöisestä Open
Design-nimisestä Harnessista?
En oo.
Ei, ei. Sä oot nyt erikoistunut
Joo. Sain klark. Joo.
näihin kaikkiin erikoisharnesseihin.
Sillä
onko tälläkin joku 49
Täytyy pitää tämmönen.
Siel on kaks tähtee, toinen on mun
tähtejä GitHubissa?
Tällasta namedroppailua
Serebras tekee omia hardware-chippejä,
minkä takia niillä on niin nopea se
inferenssi.
Joo, kyllä juuri näin.
Siis se oli aivan käsittämätön se eka
kerta kun silloin niitä metan
llama-malleja ja pystyin ajelleen siellä.
Tuntuu, niinkuin, siis nehän oli ihan
niinku tyyliin reaaliaikasta.
Ne tuottaa kokonaisen tekstin sillä,
että sä et ehdi kissaa sanoa,
niin miettii sitä tulevaisuutta,
että kun itsekin on elänyt niinku
käynyt purkeissa aikoinaan 2400-bittisen
modemin kanssa
ja nykyään on valokuitua,
niin siinä on aikamoinen ero siinä,
että kuinka nopeasti sitä tekstiä ja
mitä tahansa sisältöä tuohon sitten,
että nykyään pystytään tekemään
reaaliaikaisesti podcastia verkon yli.
Kyllä tuo inferenssikin tulee nopeutumaan
tästä huomattavasti ja
se tulee kans sitten mullistamaan aika
paljon asioita,
kun miettii
Hmm.
sitä, että just
tähän open designiin liittyen,
siis se on Claude Design käytännössä
Open Source versio ja
ja ajelin sitä tuossa yksi päivä ja
tein prototyyppii kotona just sillä
tavalla,
että mulla oli Qweni Siihen voi valita se
harness,
millä sitä ajaa, siinä oli Pi jossa oli
Qweni ja sitten siinä oli Open Design.
Yllättävän hyvää jälkeä tuli.
Sillä tavalla, että mä iteroin sitä.
että se ei tuhonnu kontekstiin sillä,
että ei ois pystynyt enää tekemään.
Sen takia mietin, vaan tossa tuli mieleen
viime viikolla,
että vois koittaa silleen, että ottais
cerebraksen
Mmm.
Koska sit se olis aika hurjaa,
kun sä saat laadukasta hyvää fronttii
nopeesti.
Ja tässä.
Sanoo vaan. Okei. Niin siis mietin sitä
cerebrasiin joskus,
kun sieltä tulee se 1000 tokenii
sekunnissa niin se alkaa olla jo semmonen
nopeus,
että tavallaan tulee pyyntöpalvelimelle,
niin sä voit vaan lennosta generoida joka
userille omat HTML:t sen kanssa.
Kyllä. Kyllä.
Tätä.
Mä oon miettinyt
tuota just nopeuspuolta, että sit jos
pystyis tekee tuolla reaaliaikaisesti
niinku
isoja kokonaisuuksia, niin se mikä nyt
ehkä noissa tavalla,
että toi reasoning on vielä tuntunut,
että se on vähän nää niinku
karvalakki lähestyminen että
jos miettii vaikka miten me ajatellaan,
kun mä puhun nyt omasta puolestaan,
niin mä en nyt rupea ole, että miten te
ajattelette,
ite käyn aina niit tavallaan
englanniksi ajattelet.
niin englanniksi hienosti ajattelen aina
ja myös ranskaksi ja välillä
espanjaksi.
Joo, mä ajattelen yleensä latina.
Mut niinku...
Aivan.
~
Ja tietty nuolenpää kirjoitukselia.
ja pysty johtaa siitä kaikki muut
kieltä.
Joo ja pimeässä ajattelee Braillena.
Hei hei hei
Joskus miettiny sitä, että kun ajattelee
vaikka duunissa ongelmia,
niin mä käyn semmosia iteraatioita
tavallaan päässä läpi.
Jos mä teen näin, tavallaan sitä
skenaarioa,
että sä käy nyt tosi nopeasti tavallaan
prototyyppaan semmosia
karvallakkiajatuksia, että jos mä teen
noin,
niin sit se menee näin, jos mä teen
näin,
se menee näin. Että sä käyt tavallaan
polkuja läpi.
Ja sit sä mietit, että mikä näistä
tuntuu järkevimmältä vähän semmoinen
intuitio, joku alitajuinen prosessointi
varmaan,
mikä siinä on.
Toi tuntuu hyvä, tos on hyvä gut
feeling,
mennään tolla. Niin vähän niinku
puuttuu vielä se,
koska se kuitenkin generointi on niinku
suhteellisen hidasta siihen,
mitä se niinku voisi olla. Että mitä
nyt Cerebras se nyt niinku
on esimerkki tai makua siitä,
niinku mitä kohti ollaan menossa.
Niin sit sä voisit oikeesti tehdä niinku
monta iteraatiota siitä samasta
ja katsoa, mikä niistä niinku käy
järkeen ja sit valita
sen parhaimman iteraatio ja mennä sillä.
Että voisi oikeesti, siellä ois sitä
niinku...
Mielestäni se on lähempää ajattelua
kuin reasoning,
se olevinaan. Ehkä se siis malli
tavallaan menee liian filosofiseksi
keskusteluun,
mutta se ole vielä ajattelua Mutta sitten
se voi seikkailla ongelmanratkaisutilassa
ja kokeilla juttuja,
niin sitten se alkaa olla enemmän
ajattelua.
Kyllä. Niin, siis tuo on ihan hyvä
kulma,
että mitä ne reasoning-tokenit oikeasti
tekee siinä,
että millaista rooliin ne pelaa siinä
kokonaisuudessa.
Sehän on nimenomaan vaan, se generoi
itselleen enemmän tietoa
sen asian ympäriltä, jotta se voisi
tehdä paremman lopullisen
Hmm.
vastauksen. Onko ajattelu sitä?
Niin. Ja jotkut varhaiset
RAG-implementaatiot
käyttivät, että mallin annettiin
generoida vastaus
ja sen sijaan,
että haettiin suoraan kysymyksellä
vaikka jotain materiaalia jostain
vektorikannasta, niin otettiinkin mallin
generoima vastaus,
mikä saattaa olla
Ja haettiin sillä.
ihan niin kuin
väärin, mutta haettiin niitä sitten
vertaatiin niihin oikeisiin vastauksiin.
Hmm. Hmm. Hmm.
Tämä
on varmaan sama ajatus tuossa
reasoningissa.
Se generoi siihen alkuun asiaa,
joka liippaa riittävän lähelle,
että se pysyy tavallaan oikealla
trackilla
se todennäköisyydet oikeaan vastaukseen
lopullisesti.
Kyllä
Niin eiks ne ole ihan alkupää niistä
reasongin malleja,
siellä oli hyvin pitkälti tuntua,
että se perustu vaan tiettyihin reasonin
tokeneihin,
että niihin entäs jos ja odotas wait.
Joo kyllä, joo.
Siellä oli vähän
Mmm.
semmosia, ei ne ole stop wordia,
mutta semmosia, mitkä ohjasivat mallin
ajattelua sillä,
että väkisin tungettiin se wait jonnekin
sinne
Joo.
Hmm.
väliin ja sitten se noin pakko tavallaan
jatkaa sitä merkkiä noin siitä,
että ootas ja
Kyllä.
sitten se noin pakko miettiä jotain muuta
ratkaisuja,
että se vähän niinku
Vähän niinku tää mitä mä kuvaillin,
Kävisi kenariot läpi.
et voi vähän seikkailla niis...
Kyllä.
Niin.
Koska muutenhan noi on semmosii et se
menee siinä ajatteluputkesta tavallaan
niinku
tokeni kerralla ja sit se vaan niinku
vahvistaa sitä omaa tietyllätapaa
biassii
että on nyt se oikea vastaus,
koska se menee vasta niinku yhtä polkuu
pitkin.
Mmh, kyllä.
Reasoning on myös jossain määrin aivan
turha suurimmassa osassa keissejä
Miettii isoa osaa, vaikka AI tai jotain
agenttiinvalmentaatioita,
ne kutsuu jotain funktioita. Sanotaan,
että voiks sä hei Linear-botti tehdä
tästä tiketti.
Se on aika esim. tarvisi reasoningia
käyttää.
Toki en tiedä, miten se on säädetty
vaikka heillä,
mutta se prompti pitää itsessään
sisällään sen.
joo, mitä sen pitää tehdä.
Ei siinä tarvitse ratkoa mitään.
Hold on, the user wants me to call this
function
Mm.
wait,
but what if he...
Joo, siel.
mutta on muuta funktioita.
näe.
Se voi olla jopa niinku reasoning vika,
että se sunkin opus lähti sinne toisen
worktreehin palloilemaan.
Et se veti itensä jengoille siellä
ajattelussa.
Mulla oli siis sama, että toki siinä oli
kyllä user error,
mutta vipestelin tai siis multipaskasin
sisäsi muutamia protoja,
mitä mietiskelin ja pistin niitä sinne
vähän taustalle pyöreistä.
Mulla oli VS Code-ikkunoita useampi ja sit
sieltä tuli vastaus ja
sit mä klikkasin vaan väärää ikkunaa
vähän ohi.
ja sitten kirjoitin se mun feedback ja
siihen painoi enteri
eli siis niinku väärään projektiin ja
sit se
Hei
opus oli hetken hetkinen mut ei mitään.
Sit se lähti sieltä toisesta projektista
korjaamaan sinne toiseen projektiin sitä
tavallaan issueta ja sit mä olin vaan et
mitä se niinku,
jaa, no itseasiassa se meni ihan hyvin,
et se oli ihan fine. Se teki ihan hyvän
korjauksen sinne mut,
mut vähän semmonen et, hmm.
Mulla kävi lähes samanlainen,
siis mä en multi-paskaan, mä
multi-taskaan,
mä oon tosi hyvä siinä. Mä oon
harjoittelut sitä kymmeniin vuosia.
Ja ajatteleet englanniksi samalla ja
latinaksi.
Joo kyllä.
Ei virheitä.
Ja tota se mun virhe oli se, että mä
loin uuden work treein,
mutta sit mä menin niinku, koska mä oon
terminaalissa,
mä en siis stoppaan sen Clauden sieltä
ja sit mä vaan CD-llä menen siihen work
treeihin ja mä mä menin väärään work
treeihin ja sanoin,
että let's get cracking.
Sitten se toteutti sen koko featurein
siihen toiseen branchiin Siellä
on toinen agentti tekee sitä omaa
ominaisuutta ja toinen tulee sinne
sotkemaan.
Sitten ne on ihan pihaalla molemmat.
Mitäs nämä on? Jaa no se käyttäjä
siellä varmaan..
molemmat järkeilee siellä. Minkä takia
tänne tulee tämmöisiä ihan
ihme muutoksia, mitä mä en tehnyt.
Sitten mulla oli hirveän solmujen
irrottaminen sen jälkeen,
että mä sain irrotettua sen taas sinne
oikeeseen vanhan...
alkuperäiseen worktreehin jossa sen piti
mennä niiden muutosten,
koska ne teki hyvin samantyyppistä juttua
ja koski samoihin tiedostoihin.
Se oli aika monen no mistake.
Ei keskustelua.
Tässä
on hyvin kuvaa tätä meidän,
että ei tehdä niitä virheitä
musiikissa eikä elämässä.
Ei. Jos mietit tässäkin, taas tämä
ihminen,
taas se heikoin lenkki näissäkin
tapauksissa.
Niin, kyllä.
Mutta sitten ei aina kuitenkaan.
Sitten tulee sitä ihmeellistä
Kyllä.
sekoilua. Just oli hyvä esimerkki
tämmöisestä...
En nyt selitä kaikkea detaljaa,
mutta tuli siis niin tyhmä ehdotus
Fablelta,
että piti oikein kysyä, että miten
ajattelit,
että nyt kun sinä tätä suunnitelmaa
tehnyt tämän kymmenen minuuttiin,
niin miten sitten vuoden päästä,
kun meillä on näitä tätä sisältöä
täällä palvelussa,
niin kuin tuhansia itemeitä niin miten
sitten se suunnitelma?
Niin kuin toimii siinä. Joo, no eihän se
kyllä toimi.
Ollenkaan. You're absolutely right.
Ja mietiät.
Frontier intelligence.
nimenomaan, oli fable. Niin kuin mä just
selitin,
joku päivä laitoin teillekin viestiin
siitä,
että kun mä olin siis, ajattelin,
että mä teen siivousurakan siellä mun
repossa ja mä ajattelin,
että käytetään fableen siihen
suunnitteluun ja mä sanoin oikein vaan
niinku
reteesti että spawn subagents Sehän on
iso virhe fablen kanssa,
koska sit niinkuin neljä minuuttia
myöhemmin mun koko quota oli käytetty.
Ja se jäi aivan kesken.
se oli periaatteessa siis hyödytön,
että minulla olisi pitänyt varmaan antaa
sen mennä läpi.
Mutta fakta on se, koska me joudumme
vielä jatkaa töittetekoa sen jälkeen,
niin minulla meni 400 euroa kredittejä
siitä minun ekstraspendistä,
kun se oli käyttänyt minun quotan
Halpaa hupia
Se on tosi
Olihan meillä...
Eiku piti vaan sanoa, et onhan meillä
tää yhteinen tuttava,
joka käytti lähemmäs tota...
Meni vähän useampi. Tonnikin,
oli vähän codexii pistänyt laulamaan.
Joo.
Kyllähän näit tota...
Kyllä se on. Hyvi, hyvin.
mutta lopputulos
on kuulemma hieno.
On, on kyllä. Olen nähnyt, todistanut ja
voin allekirjoittaa
Kyllä.
voidaan
ottaa henkilö joskus tänne vieraaksi
kertomaan siitä.
Joo, vaan samaa mieltä. Siellä on vaan
hyviä sotatarinoita näistä.
AI Rambo.
Ehdottomasti.
Tästä oikeasti näkee sen, en tykkää
token-maxingista yhtään.
Tuntuu, että kun jotkut pelaa tätä
peliä silleen,
heidän metriikka on, paljonko tokeneita
tuli käytettyy.
Aikaisemmin olen aina ihmetellyt sitä,
että miten voi olla, että minulla on
useampi asia koko ajan ja minulla
ei koskaan tokenit yli sen quotan.
niin kuin Spawn Sub-Agents, sitten mä
olen että no nyt mä ymmärrän,
että...
Mikä teidän mielipide on
tekemisen tavoillaan.
ylipäässä subagenteista?
Mä itse tykkään siitä ajatuksesta ja
käytän niitä yleensä siinä
tilanteessa, kun mun pitää tehdä paljon
semmoista rinnakkaista asiaa,
eli joku yksittäinen asia moneen eri
paikkaan.
Silloin mä tykkään, se kontekstin
käyttö on järkevämpää,
kun jokaisen näihin vaikka alihakemistoon
menee omaa agentti ja tekee
sen itse asian siellä ja sitten palaa
niiden tulosten kanssa sinne,
niin kun master.
masterille, ne on semmosia, missä mä
käytän yleensä subagentteja
Ne toimii mun mielestä niissä ihan hyvin
testeillä.
Mulla siis käytän kanssa, mutta mulla on
vähän sellainen pelko,
kun en tiedä, mitä se toimii.
Meneekö sille se mun aikaisempi
keskusteluhistoria,
jos mä oon vaik jutellu jostain teemoista
tai asioista sen mallin kanssa,
niin meneekö ne myös sille subagentille?
Hmm.
Jos mä sanon, että me ollaan juteltu
vaikka jostain Featuresta,
mikä pitää tehdä, käyty jotain
edgecaseja läpi ja sitten sanoi,
että
No, pistä muutaman agentti tekee näitä
featureita.
Joo.
Meneekö varmasti ne tiedot niille?
Vai onko se täysin uusi sessio,
vai saako se sitä historiaa sen mukana,
vai päättääkö se tavallaan
pääagentti kaiken,
mitä se saa tietää?
Harnessi määrittelee sen tehtävän
Jep.
annon sen alkuperäisen kontekstin ja
silloin se riippuu varmaan siitä mitä
Harnessia käyttää.
Mutta jos miettii Claude Coden
tapauksessa, mitä yleensä tulee
käytettyä,
niin se ei ole niin läpinäkyvää.
Joo.
Sieltä
saisi jostain kaivettua, kun menisi
vähän logeja kattomaan
saa kaivettua, joo, että se on hyvä,
siellä on logit, mutta kukapa niitä
kauheasti käy
Mmm.
kattelemaan selleen, ellei sitten oikeasti
tuu tämän vähän niinku akateeminen
mielenkiinto siihen asiaan.
Jep.
Mäkään en nyt osaa Claude Codesta
varmaksi sanoa,
että kuinka paljon sitä kontekstia sinne
laitetaan per subagentti
ainakin sinne fiilis, että noista
subagenteista on valtava hyöty siinä kun
tehdä
jotain tällaista planäilyä tai silloin
kun se malli orientoituu siellä repossa,
että se pystyy lähettämään niitä
tavallaan pieniä
Mmm.
tutkijabotteja sinne katsomaan ja vähän
vastailemaan kysymyksiin.
Siinä on järkee sit näissä ihan
asiakascaseissäkin,
niin on itse tullut ratkottua käytännön
ongelmia sillä,
että kun sulla on se main, tavallaan kuin
chatti threadi ja sitten sulla
on vaikka RAG-haku
niin sitten se tavallaan haku on tehty
subagentilla just sen takia,
että jos sieltä hausta tulee niinkuin
hiukankin ylimääräistä noisea niin
se subagentti voi suodattaa sen
Mm.
turhan noisen pois ja palauttaa sinne
päächatin vaan relevantit hakutulokset,
niin sitten se päächat pysyy niinku
jotenkin linjassa,
että siellä ei ole sit kontekstissa
jotain semmosia,
nyt puhutaan niinku lääketieteen
chatissa,
niin siellä olisi tuloksia jostain ihan
niinku toisesta taudista
tai toisesta niinkuin asiasta,
niin sitten
se malli ei myöskään sekoile niin
paljon siellä pää-chatissa koska sillä
ei ole myöskään sitä väärää
kontekstia siellä.
Siinä subagentit ovat tosi hyviä,
mutta siinä on aina se käytännön
ongelma,
että mitä sitten, jos se subagentti jos
siinä on just se rikkinäinen puhelin,
että siellä on ollut jotain hyviä
hakutuloksia,
mutta sitten ne eivät vain päädy sinne
pää-chatiin.
Kyllä.
Yleensä kun subagenteissa myös
käytetään vähän pienempiä malleja,
että ne ovat nopeita, niin
tippuuks sieltä asioita sormien
välistä,
mitä olisi ehkä pitänyt kuitenkin
päätyä sinne päächattiin.
Tokiaan siihen voi tehdä sitten
kaikenlaista evalssiä,
mutta sitten kaikkea aina hidastuu,
mitä enemmän varmistuskerroksiin,
niin UX kärsii aina.
Hmm.
Kyllä
viiveet kasvaa välttämättä noissa,
mutta tuosta tuli mun mielestä ihan hyvä
summeeraus ainakin siitä,
että mä ajattelen subagentteja
nimenomaan tuon context engineeringing
kautta,
että ne on tapa millä mä pystyn
hallitsemaan sitä kontekstiä paremmin
siinä
mun tehtävänsä. Mikä se tehtävä sit
onkaan?
Hmm.
Toisaalta tekisi melkein mieli kokeillakin
joskus.
Jos ei olis niinku se yksikkökustannus ei
ole niin kriittinen niin
sä voisit periaatteessa jos sulla olis
vaik tämmönen hakusubagentti niin
sä voisit tehdä sen saman haun
neljällä rinnakkaisella tuommoisella
pienemmän
Mmm.
mallin haulla ja sit vaan palauttaa ne
tavallaan konsensus tulokset sinne.
Mm-hmm.
tai tuoda niistä kaikista neljästä,
että siinä olisi vähän semmoista
hajontaa kanssa,
että se ei ole yhden yhdestä tavallaan
pyörähdyksestä kiinni enää vaan,
että siinä olisi enemmän vielä mahiksi
saada sitä relevanttia kamaa siinä
päätsättiin.
Tämä on tällainen klassinen pyydä
toinen mielipide.
Mmm.
Niin,
just näin.
Toistetaan näitä tuolla digitaalisessa
maailmassa.
Mutta sitähän se on. En tiedä,
kuinka paljon te teette sitä,
että kun miettii jotain uutta ongelmaa
tai miettii nimenomaan sitä ratkaisua
johonkin uuteen ongelmaan, niin sitten
kyselee vähän
eri mallilta feedbackia siihen ajatukseen.
Saa vähän eri painoilta vastauksia
Mh?
ja vähän mietittävää. Aina sieltä
teet hyvää kamaa,
mutta sitten se herättelee itseään
ehkä pohtimaan jotain tiettyä asiaa
uudelleen.
mitä aikaisemmin ei sit miettinyt.
Joskus tulee tehty sitä, että tekee
jonkun pläniin vaikka fablella
ja sitten lähettää sen GPT-lle ja
sanoi,
että teidän kilpailija teki
tämmöiseen.
Onko tämä nyt ihan hyvä?
Ja sitten sanotaan, että Astra vaikka
vastaisi jotain,
antaisi sen takaisin fablelle.
Ei tää nyt ollut ihan hyvä tää plani.
Hmm.
Niin, noissa on se vaarallinen puoliko.
No ne niin miellyttäjiä,
Mm-hmm.
noin
kielimallit. Sitä aina, jos sä pyydät
niin ku...
etsi virheitä, niin ainahan ne löytää
jotain.
Harvemmin ne vastaa, että ei,
että tää on ihan solid tässä on
niinku mitään.
Kyllä sä et sit melkeen puoliväkisin
niinku löytyy jotain.
Tai jos sä kysyt, että, että eiks tää
olekin tosi hyvä,
niin... ...usein se sit kallistuu siihen,
että on kyl tosi hyvä. Et ei sä et
niinku...
Vähän...
Vähän ehkä näissä niinku uudemmissa
malleissa on ollut sitä,
että nyt hiukan tulee semmoista hyvää
pushbackia välillä.
Et kun sanoi, että hei, mulla on
tämmöinen bisnessuunnitelma,
että mä haluan ottaa vanhoja
kertakäyttö-
mukeja, mä pesen ne ja myyn ne
eteenpäin,
eikö olisikin hyvä. Ja sit se on vaan,
että yes, kuin että hyvä, yes.
Niin kyllä enemmän tulee nyt sitä,
että ei toi välttämättä oo niinku
hyvä,
hyvä suunnitelma. Se on ollut ehkä sinne
pieni muutos tässä vuoden aikana.
Sehän hauskaa tuli vaan mieleen tästä
kehumisesta.
Paras on, kun tekee planiä ja sitten se
lukee sen seuraavassa stepissa sen.
Se on aina, good and solid plan.
Tulee
Mmmh...
mieleen se meemi missä Obama antaa
mitalin itelleen
jotenkin niin hauska tämmöinen
positiivinen viba koko ajan.
Minun oli ihan pakko kysyä nyt Claudelta
tästä
mun bisnessuunnitelmasta mielipidettä
Mitä mieltä
Heh
Ihan vaan testatakseen Mites lähtee?
Evaluating, cup washing and resell
business idea.
Hei
hei hei hei hei
Joo ja sit se
kysyy tai se tietysti ylistää varmaan,
että tässä voisi olla jotain ja sit jos
ei se ole riittävä skeptinen,
niin sit ite haluaa vähän puskea jotain
ajatuksia,
että no mut eiks tää nyt oo vähän
typerä idea,
niin sit se taas myötäilee sitä.
No sä
Mmm.
oot kyllä ihan oikees, ei tässä oo
mitään järkeä.
Mutta se silti tää on aika hyvä idea
eiks vaan?
Onhan tää nyt joo, saa sä.
Mmm, niin. Et kysy et saa just sitä mitä
haluaa.
Niinpä. Kyllä. Niin hyvässä kuin
pahassa.
Mm-hmm. Mikäs se on?
Tämä on tosi pitkä vastaus.
Tämä hyvin Claudemainen vastaus.
Tämä
Mmm.
on uusi ongelma, että joutuu Clauden
vastauksiin aina sanomaan, et voiko
se tiivistää.
TL ; DR
Niin.
Joo, on siis yksi ongelma,
Sitten hän itse asiassa... Joo.
oli tässä, se on laiton bisnes
A, okei, no... Nyt
Laiton?
Nyt on raju Miten sä saat
kertakäyttömukeista laitonta bisnestä?
Tää
on nyt niinku... Tää rupes kutkuttamaan.
Washing single use cups. Ne
Aah...
They're not built for rotations.
Aijaa. Höh.
Höh.
Kyllä ne kyl käytännössä kestää
aika kauan.
Hmm.
Mmm.
Jep.
No pitää miettiä joku uusi startti
sitten.
Tästä ei tullut meidän uutta Get Rich
Quick.
Pitää jatkaa näitä IT hommia vielä
ainakin hetki.
Mä sanon että jokaisessa jaksossa
meidän pitää vähintään muutaman
bisnesidean kehittää. mikä se on?
Built in public.
Joo.
Joo,
mutta tämä kaatui nyt aika nopeasti
tämä idea.
Siinä ei montaa minuuttia mennyt.
Joo, mutta tämä on
Tää on tämmöstä.
Fail fast.
Kyllä.